as if some fear is some big unknowable
scary awful thing well mostly it's not
most fear is just bad management of our
own mental faculties
i realized i could no longer hide from
my insecurities
high from all these fears i just start
wearing them if you want to be
successful in business
you're not going to succeed on a large
scale until you face the threshold of
control and once you face it you'll face
it again and again but it'll become an
old friend
wanna be happy live a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn
how to get rid of fear forever
okay let's kick it off with way number
one switch your perspective with david
goggins
every day in my life i'm haunted by my
father
the kids that bullied me my own
insecurities
all these things with this this this
roost in the back of my head
so i'll be driving home at like seven
o'clock in the morning
from all night shift and all alone in my
truck
and i'll be thinking what the [ __ ] man
my life is hell
so one day i came home and i always come
on watch tv
and this show was on with like navy
seals yeah
and um i'm afraid the water terrify the
water i sink like a rock so i'm sitting
there watching these guys going through
navy seal training
and i'm like and i saw with
what i believed how look how a man
should feel
very you know have pride and dignity
himself yeah so i got to change myself
so literally i sat down on the couch and
watched these guys going through seal
training
and i went through my own mental
checklist
of how [ __ ] up i am and how many
things i would have to change
just to get an opportunity to try out
for something like that
have to get smarter have to get fit have
to lose weight have to
do all these things start running
swimming everything
so i finally get to a point where um i
get the courage
to go to a recruiter and say hey i want
to go try to do this but when you're 297
pounds and you're gonna go try to be one
of the fittest people in the world
yeah you get laughed at so i got laughed
at a lot
but in this process this process was
actually hardening my mind
all the laughter because the laughter
used to make me cower
now i realized i could no longer hide
from my insecurities
hide from all these fears i just start
wearing them yeah had to start talking
about how to start being vulnerable
because i was always afraid of them so
here i am now
i'm facing them i finally find a
recruiter that says hey we'll take you
in
and he says you have less than three
months to lose 106 pounds
i'm like that's you know that's possible
so
that was my mindset i was like hey i
can't have that kind of mindset
so i went to the dungeon and started
using all my insecurities
as strength instead of looking at being
bullied
and and uh my dad messing me up and all
this stuff like that i looked at it as
who could have survived all this and
still be here with the
opportunity to go to navy seal training
and so i started using all these
negative things and started flipping
everything on top of his head
instead of saying what was me kicking
rocks head down in the dirt
i started saying there's nothing on the
planet
who would have this opportunity coming
from where i came from
they would be a statistic yeah so i
started looking at it as power
versus like big time defeat and slowly
but surely
every day i started changing the voice
in my head because the
the most important conversation you will
ever have
is the one you have with yourself yeah
so i slowly started changing that
internal dialogue
in my head and there was no like teacher
there was no shrink there was no mom
saying hey david you can do it
let's let's no it was right me and that
was where the power came from the power
came from
no one's helping me no one's coming back
to
save me no one's coming back to pull me
to the finish line
this is on you so i saw a lot of power
in the fact that
if i change this around i
i did this i changed this around way
number two
push yourself outside your comfort zone
with warren buffett
somebody once said that the chains of
habit
are too light to be felt until they're
too heavy to be broken
i had been terrified of public speaking
i couldn't do it i'd throw up
i knew if i didn't cure it then i never
cured
and so i saw an ad in the paper for the
dale carnegie course
which worked on developing your ability
to speak in public
and i went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail
they made us all these crazy things to
get out of ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things
[Applause]
[Music]
if i hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
[Music]
so in my office you will not see the
degree i got from the university of
nebraska
you'll not see the master's degree i got
from columbia university
but you'll see the little award
certificate i got from the dale carnegie
course way number three understand what
fear
is with brendan burchard i believe that
fear
gets way too much airplay you know i
think so many people say well
people don't take action because they
have too much fear or fear is holding
people back and i think this is so
common in our our language it's almost
the point where it's almost comedic it's
ridiculous it's
like what are they fearful of what are
they so scared of you know we we live in
the modern world right now where
there's not all these impulsive fears
that are are driven by a physical
reality to be safe you know we're not
being
chased by animals that are trying to
kill us often right
so most of the fears that we actually
have are just
negative contemplative thoughts that
we're rerunning
too often and we're associating so much
pain to that now becomes convenient oh
it's fear
as if some fear is some big unknowable
scary awful thing well mostly it's not
most fear is just bad management of our
own mental faculties
it's not an impulsive physical thing
generating in our brain
telling us to you know fight fight or
flee and everyone wants to use that
excuse you know we still have
all these you know biological
psychologists or people running around
saying well
it's just an impulsive thing that people
can't understand or
or or be conscious of right it's the
unconscious fears it's just
wiping us out it's like get over it
neuroscience has shown like we have much
more
powerful capabilities than most of us
think that we do and the reality is
most fear once you understand what it
actually
is and it usually is a contemplative
process
and once they understand what it is then
it's like oh we can overcome it
because what is it then i mean what is
fear what are we so scared of
what's going to hurt us what is this
thing that we fear is going to bring so
much pain in our lives
ever thought about it what is it what is
the thing that we're so
scared that's gonna bring in all this
pain to our lives
i remember figuring this out for myself
and
when i did i wasn't so scared anymore
because sometimes you know the things
once you understand them more
they're not so terrifying once something
becomes knowable
you can develop competency around it
once you can develop competency around
it
then you can develop confidence around
it there's this old thing in psychology
we call
the competence confidence loop the more
you understand something
the more confidence you have in that
area same thing with anything that does
happen to
impulsively generate some fear in
yourself well now once you understand
what it is
you can deal with it better all right my
friend evan carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
way number four meditate joe dispenza a
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality to our
victimization our guilt our suffering
our shame our unworthiness our
self-doubt
or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are
those are the first three hormonal
centers in the body and and those first
three centers have everything to do with
survival
and those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress
is a lot of energy that we're drawing
from our very
vital life force yes a resource of light
and information
and we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally
robbing the body's energy right so so
then living like that for the short term
is okay because the body can move back
to homeostasis it can restore itself but
when we're over doing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair
because you're living constantly in
survival so again you can eat all the
right food you can do all the right
things but if you're living in anxiety
and fear
and you're viewing your world from the
worst case scenario that could possibly
happen because that's what you do in
survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so
the majority of our thoughts are
signaling
certain circuits in the brain that
signal another part of the brain
limbic brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as
energy in these energy centers and and
if you're living in survival why would
you open your heart
i mean it's just not a time to open your
heart i mean if you're getting chased by
t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fight or hide and so is
that why we're this way i've never asked
you this before is this some
uh i don't i don't think you believe
this but i just want to understand is
this some sort of
genetic disposition that's been passed
down to us since we've been chased by
t-rex
i think so i think survival has been
very adaptive yeah like because if
you're being chased by t-rex
you don't run up to t t-rex and say oh
cute little dinosaur let me pet you
that's not adaptive
and fear is adaptive you run from the
unknown you run from challenges right
yes
so if you're living in survival there's
better chances of surviving
if you run from the unknown and by the
way
when you're living in survival at the
infinite potentials in the quantum field
you'll select the worst case scenario in
your mind
and you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because
you have better chances of surviving
there you go if you prepare for the
worst right
so people spend their whole life yes
thinking about the worst thing and
emotionally embracing it while you take
a thought and emotion or an
image and an emotion you're branding or
conditioning your body
into what anxiety right into fear so
then you keep doing that over and over
again over and over again your
the body becomes the mind of fear and
whether you think you can control it or
not you're gonna have a panic attack
and the panic attack is the body saying
you've conditioned me this way try as
you may with your conscious mind and
control it
right you programmed it subconsciously
then you start worrying about the next
panic attack and it's that very
anticipation
it keeps the person on the hamster wheel
robs them of all of this energy
as well they're absolutely so so so they
don't believe
in possibility when they're living in
that state because
in survival it's not a time to create
all the blood flow is going to the hind
brain and away from the forebrain
there's no there's there's no physiology
really for a person to begin to create a
new future
so then so think about it so then 70
of the time people in the world are
living
anticipating the next moment based on
their past moment and so
they're laying reality down moment by
moment with the next known
the next predictable moment and so the
hormones of stress
endorse the senses our senses become
heightened when we're under stress and
we become materialists we narrow our
focus on the danger
yes so then you're focusing on matter
you're focusing on the material world
and when you do that you put all your
attention the arousal of the stress
hormones
puts all your attention on your body if
you're being chased by t-rex you better
be paying attention to your body
when people start reaching this moment
my goodness
they're overcoming themselves and now
they're at that perfect
place to create and my definition of
creation is when i forget about myself
that's when you're free so some people
can do it because
they practice it other people can't get
beyond the addiction
of a certain emotion that means their
body is still their mind yes
so then if you're sitting in a
meditation and your body's thrown the
kitchen sink at you and saying
ed you're a loser you're never gonna
change this is too hard why don't you
quit
and you're aware that that's your body
doing that and you say to your body
we're gonna sit here and we're going to
sit in this fire and i'm going to keep
applying the formula
and my your brain starts running to all
the emails you have to do and you become
aware of that and return back to the
present moment
and you tell the body it's no longer the
mind that you're the mind
now your will is getting greater than
that program and there's a liberation of
energy and every time you do that
that's a victory and you teach every
time you do that that's a victory when
your mind tells the body i'm in charge
when you say you're when you you just
want to get up and you want to quit you
got no
no that's my body bring it back okay and
now you're now you're
taming the animal the body is the animal
and you're like a dog you sit
and if you keep doing this keep doing
this you're climbing on top and the body
finally acquiesces it finally says
i'm not going anywhere and then boom
there's this liberation of energy what's
the side effect
joy person's heart just automatically
opens up
and and every time they do that those
victories
add up there's no such thing as a bad
meditation
there's only overcoming yourself and
when you
sit in the fire and you work with that
people say to me why do you meditate
every morning i say because if i can
overcome myself in the morning the rest
of my day is easy
it's easy true because because that's
what it's about you master yourself you
master your life yes and so then
all the chatter in your head that you
listen to all day long
that is called the default mode network
in the brain our research shows
that shuts off not just shuts off during
the meditation it stays shut off for the
rest of the day so the critic in your
head that's telling you this will never
happen you don't have enough time
all right that there's no voice there so
you just have a clear
flow of where you're going and you trust
yourself more way number five
rewire your mind with marissa peer i see
people with a lot of phobias and
phobias are very common and people who
come and go i've got this fear of flying
i've got this fear of heights i've got
this
really terrible fear of public speaking
you know i have to stand up at work and
chair a meeting out my mouth and i go uh
uh and now i feel such an
idiot what's wrong with me i'm just such
a loser and they kind of beat themselves
up but you know
your brain is actually quite smart and
it usually gives you a phobia because it
thinks it's in your best
interest to have it now i know that
sounds kind of crazy
but the mind works like this it always
does what it
really thinks is in your very very best
interest if you have a phobia
and you haven't managed to get rid of it
that's because your mind believes that
somehow it's helping you
so here's the thing if you go to the top
of a very tall building and
run to the window and look out your
stomach will drop and your mind will go
get away from the edge you crazy full
because
millions of years after evolution our
brain still thinks
if we stand right at the top of a high
building it should make us feel slightly
sick
so we pull back and now it saved us
because that's our mind's job
keep you safe on the planet so i totally
understand the fear of heights and
you can't fight that stuff vertigo is
there for a reason
but you can rationalize with the mind
you can turn it down you can say i'm
safe
look there's a window this thick i'm
going to stay here and breathe and keep
saying i'm
safe i'm safe and then the vertigo will
go away because
your mind is doing its job get you away
from the ledge and when you
dialogue with your mind ago it's not a
ledge it's a plate glass window and i'm
safe it will go oh okay
don't need to do my job way number six
practice doing scary things with jocko
willink
in the discipline equals freedom field
manual the section
fear reads how do you overcome feel
fear of failure step go
but a previous entry reads i don't want
you to overcome
fear of failure i want you to be afraid
of failure
mind elaborating yeah clearly there's a
dichotomy here
i know it's my favorite word apparently
according to dean lister yes
i agree there is a dichotomy here
because
fear is something good that you should
take advantage of
so it's kind of good to be afraid
because it keeps you on age edge it
keeps you from slacking
it keeps you preparing as much as you
possibly can and all that stuff is good
but
at the same time yes if you go too far
to the other end of the spectrum
fear gets a hold of you and you can't
overcome it so you freeze or you cower
or you run away and none of those are
good reactions
so what i obviously failed to
communicate well in the book discipline
equals freedom field manual
is the dichotomy between these
spectrum the spectrum of fear that you
can have
so if you have no fear whatsoever no
fear well guess what
you get cocky you can get arrogant um
if you have too much fear you can't even
get out of the gate you just
freeze you hesitate so like all
dichotomies you got to balance those two
and the way you balance those two
is to try and do things that make you
feel fear
right try and do things that that make
you feel fear
so that way you get used to it you can
overcome it
you can deal with it you can utilize it
if you have a fighter
you ever hear ufc fighters like i'm
afraid every time i get in the ring
right
pretty much everybody yeah pretty much
everybody i'm afraid because you're
you're afraid you're going to get
knocked out you're afraid this you're
afraid that
i'm afraid i'm going to lose in front of
all my family and friends and all that
so everyone's afraid so what does that
fear do it drives you to train harder
drives you to prepare drives you to keep
your hands up and your chin down when
you're in the cage
so yeah there's a healthy level of fear
it can also get get the best of you so
keep it balanced
and we number seven the last one before
very special bonus clip
is face your threshold of control with
tony robbins
if you want to be successful in business
you're not going to succeed on a large
scale until you face the threshold of
control and once you face it you'll face
it again and again but it'll become an
old friend
because you'll keep growing what's the
threshold of control it's where
you get to the edge where you feel like
you just can't do it
like if i put a dot in the middle of
life and i go this is a problem
and if you have a comfort zone that says
that's within the things i know how to
deal with to handle it
but if this is the circle of what you
can deal with a problem is way out here
it feels out of control like i don't
know what to do so what we have to do is
we have to learn to take
where our comfort zone is and expand it
and the only way that happens quite
frankly in most cases
is you face a real challenge so i'll
give you a metaphor
um if you're gone skiing or snowboarding
and
most people that ski are terminally you
know intermediate
they get to a certain level they're okay
with and they stop really growing
and the reason is because they don't
push through their fears they hit a
threshold of control
that they can't handle and they pull
back and when you pull back your world
gets smaller
not bigger does that make sense so if
you've ever let's say you're a
intermediate skier and you're going down
a nice green easy or blue slope
and you miss the wrong turn and you hit
a double black diamond
and your whole nervous system goes oh my
god i'm gonna die i can't do it but you
can't go back there's no place to go
back it's up
and you have to go down now you got two
choices
one is you start to ski you gotta
control you look over the edge of the
cliff and you freak out and slam
yourself against the hill and hang on
for dear life to try to survive
and the people like that will never
really learn to be extraordinary in
skiing or snowboarding
and then there's the other person the
other person that says you know what
if i look at what i'm afraid of i'm
going to stay afraid i'm never going to
master this and so they focus not on
what they're afraid of they focus on
where they want to go
and they just completely block out as
much as they humanly can even though the
heart's beating like crazy
and they focus on where they want to go
and of course wherever you focus that's
where your skis go
and so soon they go back and forth and
they learn how to carve
well for me i can remember you know
being up in vancouver british columbia
canada
and i can remember being in a place
where it's like i hit my threshold of
control i was beyond what i could handle
we had
literally no money left some people that
i was working with stole money from me i
was brand new in business i didn't have
the details things were on a handshake
and i had no capital no way to do
anything
and i broke them beyond my threshold of
control there's no way to figure it out
but i did
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what are you going to do to take
action on it
this week when you write down what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action on something you have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
so i'm here in puerto rico i was invited
to speak at brendan burchard's
mastermind event these people pay 30 to
50 000
a year to be a part of his group and
i was asked to speak i was one of two
external speakers to be here over the
past
three days and before going on stage i
had a little mini
panic attack my biggest fears are going
to disappoint people my biggest fears
when i let them down my biggest fear is
that
brendan you know brought me over here
put me up in this
amazing hotel you know and uh and i'm
gonna
forget what i'm gonna say i'm gonna let
people down i'm gonna disappoint them
and it's gonna look bad for everybody
and they paid all this money to be here
and just before going on stage in the
introduction
brendan's talking about how i've helped
him and how
helped him with his youtube channel and
just backstage i dropped all these
genius
knowledge bombs on him and in my heart
i'm like freaking out even more like
man as if i wasn't already stressed out
enough you gotta
bump me up and fill me up even more
which in my head is more
expectations uh you know what people
think i'm gonna do people who may not
even know me now they're gonna be
you know putting all these expectations
on me right now i have to deliver even
more right after the big setup
i'd rather under promise over deliver
not have a giant promise and then
try to imagine so here's the thing that
saves me
and maybe it'll work with you i default
to service
when i'm stressed out when i'm anxious
this happens mostly when
when we're afraid of other people's
opinions right when when we're about to
make a youtube video when we're
about to speak on stage we're about to
do something like talking to a customer
something scary
it's usually because of other people's
opinions and
what i do is default to service when i
can catch it right if you catch yourself
feeling the panic attack default the
service
so i'll look out into the crowd and i'll
remind myself i'm not
here for me i'm here for them i'm here
for you
i'm making this video for you hopefully
you know this channel is a part of your
regular routine your morning routine and
it's giving you inspiration
and ideas and belief and hope in the
morning that's why i make these videos
it's not
because i love standing out here on the
balcony with my arm
about to fall off because i'm tired of
holding this phone up
right i'm introverted i have no
desire to to see myself on camera
every time before filming i have these
moments of anxiety
feeling like i want the new video i make
to be
better than before and so i get nervous
and scared every time i
get even still now in front of the
camera to make videos like this but
definitely to do crazy uh speeches in
front of people paying 30 to 50k to be
there
right it's about service
you're built to serve you want to help
other people
give a message that matters and so
my technique that always calms me down
and always makes me feel great
is i think this is about you this is
about
them this isn't about me
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want to know how
to destroy fear and pain check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there